l'historial du hartmannswillerkopf
souffle sa première bougie et s'offre un
beau cadeau pour son anniversaire une
fréquentation au delà des espérances 48
mille cinq cents personnes l'ont déjà
visité preuve de l'utilité de ce nouveau
lieu de mémoire de la grande guerre
stéphane baudry et réclame 9 heures il
fait désormais partie du paysage
un an après son inauguration l'historial
du hartmannswillerkopf a trouvé son
public grâce à une exposition permanente
qui restitue la bataille dans le
contexte historique et détaille les
conditions de vie des soldats
il est devenu un point de passage
incontournable pour enrichir sa visite
c'est très important de pouvoir
apprendre cette partie de l'histoire et
surtout pour les enfants pour qu'ils
comprennent bien ça permet avant de se
rendre sur le site naturel justement moi
je suis avec des enfants inquiets qu'ils
puissent et puis les adultes aussi bien
évidemment prendre connaissance d'un de
comment on est entré en guerre pourquoi
on en est arrivé là quelles sont les
conditions de vie lorsqu'on pratique la
guerre en montagne et d'un point de vue
pratique ce bâtiment offre
d'infrastructure qui manquait au site
pour accueillir les groupes et les
scolaires
il constitue aussi une solution de repli
en cas de mauvais temps ou pour les
visiteurs qui ne peuvent pas aller
jusqu'au sommet pour nos visiteurs qui
sont retraités
c'est vrai qu'à les faire deux heures de
marche sur la montagne c'est pas
forcément le plus pratique
donc il vous retrouver ici 10 ou la
possibilité de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé sur leur demande c'est leur kop
d'une manière qui sera un peu plus
adapté pour preuve de son utilité
l'historial a déjà accueilli 48 mille
visiteurs un quart des 200 milles
personnes qui fréquentent le site chaque
année c'est un outil en effet qui était
indispensable puisqu'il est à la fois
une porte d'entrée ou si de
compréhension du site est aujourd'hui
nous proposons en quelque sorte un parc
mémorielle avec son historial le
monument national et la nécropole et le
parcours scénographié du champ de
bataille
et avec un quart de visiteurs allemands
l'historial rempli sa mission de lieux
de mémoire partagée et devrait permettre
d'attirer plus de public
en un an les visites guidées ont déjà
presque doublé tout